What was again the word then for it or for him or for you formal?
La.
If we make this feminine,
So we change the O to an A, and we're gonna see other examples of this way of making something feminine in Spanish.
We get la, and this means her, it
a feminine thing.
So objects as well.
We're not not objects.
Objects don't have gender.
When people speak about languages that have gender, they tend to think that the object has the gender.
But it's not the object, it's the word
You might have two words for the same object and one might be masculine and one might be feminine.
So it's the word.
A feminine word for example usually are ones that end in A.
So like kassa.
House.
If you want to say I want to see it
And with this it, you mean the house.
What do you think you will say?
I want to see it.
Good.
Now what else could that sentence mean other than I want to see it, the feminine thing?
What else could it mean?
Oh, it it could also mean I want to see her.
Yes, exactly.
So we get quite a few meanings just with this little la and adding an S to it or changing the O to an A, we actually get a lot of options.
La could mean her and it also could mean new formal talking to a female.
So you could be saying I want to see you formally.
Now where you use the formal language and the informal language really really depends on the dialect.
So the safe way is to go in with the formal and to see what happens and to see how people address you and see how people address each other in this context and you can adjust accordingly.
For example, in Spain, when you meet somebody, when you go into a shop, when you meet somebody for the first time, with the exception of kind of young peers, the common thing is to begin speaking formally.
If I compare this to Buenos Aires, for example, in Argentina, it's almost uh never used this formal way of addressing people.
In fact, it's used more often to insult somebody with uh an extra
layer of of sarcasm or irony, let's say, then it's actually used sincerely to be formal.
So it really depends on the place.
You want to go and see, but the place safe, you can use the formal, which would be la or la
Speaking to a male or to a female, instead of te.
Quiere means he wants, she wants.
It wants or you formal want.
We can see that these four they band together, not just in words like law and la, but in the verbs as well.
We saw it with s
That S means it is, she is, he is, you fummel are.
So they will band together.
Chiere means he wants, she wants, it wants, you fummel want.
So, how would you say you want to visit me?
Quiere visitarme you want to visit me.
Now if you want to make that a question in English this we put do
Do you want but in Spanish you won't do anything like that.
In Spanish you will just make it sound like a question with your voice.
So how would you say do you want to visit me?
Good.
How'd you say you don't want to visit me?
No quiere visitarme.
Well you sounded very sad when you said that.
Now if you want to say don't you want to visit me again English gets really complicated there but not Spanish
So don't you want to visit me?
No care visitarme.
Good.
No quiere visitarme
You could have the word for why.
The word for why is porque.
Porque.
It's actually the word for because as well.
So why don't you want to visit me?
Good.
The verb for to come is veneer.
Venir.
So of course you could hear the like I just pronounced for you, so you would get the spelling venir.
But more commonly you would hear venir, venir, like a soft bee.
Firstly did say do you want to come?
Good.
Quiere venir.
A nice way to remember venir actually is conveniente, convenient with coming.
When things come together.
Or if you ever heard welcome in Spanish, you might have heard bienvenido or bienvenida, bienvenidos, bienvenidas.
Literally the same as well come, well is bien, and come there we have a benido, it's a different version of benir.
So benir to come.
If you want to say the house, it's a la casa
La casa.
What was to?
Ah.
What is to the house?
A la casa.
Good.
Do you want to come to the house?
How would you say do you want to come to visit me?
Do you want to come to visit me?
Good.
Don't you want to come to visit me?
Good, no quiere venir a visitarme.
What was the word for why?
Good.
Why don't you want to come to visit me?
Very good
Porque no quiere venir a visitar me good.
And of course here we're using a because we have venir.
a verb of coming and going like boy boy ah menir a when we're connecting to a two form
The word for IO IO in Spanish is debo, debo
Debo.
The English word debt, which is spelled D-E-B-T, has this B from Debo.
It comes from there.
We don't pronounce it in English, of course.
But this word is from Latin.
And Debo is I-O.
The useful thing about I-O is that you can use it like I must.
So if you want to say I must continue, you say I owe to continue.
I owe to continue.
And that's the meaning of I must continue.
So how would you say that?
I must continue
Tepo continuar.
Good.
How would you say I must identify it
Devo identify identification identificar
Debo identificarlo.
Good.
I must or I owe to identify them.
I must identify them.
Depo identificar los.
What if they were feminine things?
What change do you think you would say?
Las.